mobile footage records a gunman
following many rounds inside a building
where a Bible study meeting of the
Jehovah's Witnesses was taking place
outside a stream of police vehicles and
ambulances were quickly on the scene
armed police stormed the building
finding dead bodies and many injured and
escorting survivors to safety
Hamburg police have confirmed the gunman
was among the dead shooting himself on
an upper floor of a building after
police entered below
they described to miss Philip f a 35
year old German citizen and former
member of the Jehovah's Witnesses who
left the community on bad terms 18
months ago possibly suffering from
mental ill health the motive remains
unclear but terrorism has been ruled out
he appeared to be unmarried lived and
worked in Hamburg since 2014. Philip F
had a gun license for sports purposes
and was in legal possession of a weapon
titled Heckler and [__] P30 which was
the weapon found next to the perpetrator
officials say they had received an
anonymous tip-off warning the gunman
might have an undiagnosed Mental Illness
but they say when we visited his home
they had no grounds to take away his
license questions will now be asked
about whether Germany's gun laws need
changing to try and cover some five and
a half million weapons held legally in
this country
overnight Witnesses described a frenzied
scene
I'm a resident up here and I heard loud
gunshots so I went to the window to get
an idea of the situation then I saw that
a man was shooting out of the window
with a firearm there were people being
carried out and there were probably 25
shots at least that I heard and after
the police got there there was no
gunfire for a long time then after five
minutes or so there was a single shot
as forensic work continued police said
the government had fired nine magazines
of ammunition during the Rampage
the coincidental Presence at the time of
highly trained armed officers near the
Jehovah's Witness building they said had
saved many lives William peacock Al
Jazeera Hamburg